hello everyone we are back at the 1914
tournament of son Peter Berg
it's the cup of Wonka saga yet again and
Capablanca faces well old friend and
future rival Alexandra Jackson a lien
has the white pieces and in the first
part of the tournament if you remember I
didn't went for the rule opus and
Capablanca was able to win that game
with the black pieces but altogether
this is the fourth game idea he never
played against capablanca the first two
in were in 1913 in the Sabourin Cup if
you were following the clunkers Augustin
from the beginning then you have seen
those two games if not I will include a
link to both of the games in the
description below I just so you get a
sense of the history between the two
players and also I will include a list a
link to the game from the first part of
the sankt-petersburg tournament so for
those of you who are just tuning in a
couple blanca won the first half of the
tournament with a point and a half lead
then a nice hundred move draw against
world champion Emanuel asked her then
defeated dr. Zuber Tosh and then in the
previous video a seemingly easy victory
against Frank James Marshall his old
rival now again a fourth game ever
against Alexander addition let's see
what a lien has in store for for for the
Cuban legend
efore bialyan we have e5 Knight to f3
Knight to c6 and in the first part of
the tournament a lien went for the rule
opus Bishop to b5 but now Knight the c3
we have the three Knights opening and
Knight to f6 the four Knights game with
Bishop to b5 now by electing the Spanish
variation and nice to d4 a nice tricky
move by kappa blanka already going for
complications from the beginning which
is something you might expect from
anything but here maybe maybe so like a
little psychological idea on couple
Blancas part
you still can't capture i mean you can't
capture it but it it results in a really
complicated game where black gets a lot
of initiative for the point where you
can go just let's say queen e7 maybe you
can go Queen e7 attack the knight and
you will at some point when when the
bishop on be fought not one but you will
win the bishop pair for example f4y
defends the knight Knight captures
Knight captures attacked the c7 pawn
and then just d5 black will get a lot of
initiative for the pawn and white it's
hard to say if white will be able to
even keep it on the other hand you could
go over after Knight to d4 captures and
then just c6 kick the bishop away let's
say well Bishop to e2 back and then go
just d5 if or maybe d6 knight can go to
F 3 you can go Bishop to g4 and so on
and so on after exchanging on e2 of
course but a lot of ideas for black here
and the engine actually prefers Knight
captures only 5 for white but it's you
know for a human it's not something you
would enjoy playing but also here kappa
blanka tests ideally see ready to you
know mix it up
but anything goes for just the standard
Knight captures on d4 we have it
captures on d4 and now II five by Ida
him
d captures in C 3 we have he captures on
f6 Queen captures on f6 and now this is
one of the few cases where it's actually
good to play not the principal move the
principal move would be taking towards
the center with B captors and c3 going
d4 but here I white would just be too
cramped here for example c6 attacks the
Bishop Bishop d3 d5 and White's position
is somewhat you know cramped him so here
D captures on c3 is played now both the
dark square Bishop and the queen can
enter the game we have Queen to e5 check
by couple Lanka and already this is move
eight and Capablanca is very happy with
the black pieces you can see that he's
threatening to win the bishop here so
even has a chance here he can either
move back with his piece play Queen e2
or or play something weird like King to
f1 but you don't want to play that as we
already mentioned you will lose the
bishop so Queen e2 with Queen captures
Bishop captures and now just d5 and here
it's a pretty equal endgame both pairs
with the Bishop prepare the material on
the board is equal a lien with the CC
pawn but he will be able to get rid of
it at some point when he pushes c4
Bishop to f4 bialyan going after the c7
pawn also developing a piece c6 and now
just three four I didn't wants to get
his CC pawn with Bishop to e6 pawn
captures on d5 Bishop captures on d5 and
now Rahim castles we have Bishop to c5
and here rook F to e one threatening
some nasty discoveries so cuppa Blanca
castles we have Bishop to d3 and now
just a rook F to e and here there's no
good way of either player to take it
take advantage of the position a couple
of one because the bishops are maybe
somewhat better here but you know what a
wooden ball player is still having the
bishop prepare it's not like we're gonna
have any infiltrations by the rooks or
or or anything so a three
I didn't just improves perhaps prepares
to expand on the Queen side with f6 King
to f1 improving the position of the King
and now g6 with f3 violation and now
King to f7 rook captures on e8 by the
him rook captures on the 8th and now
look to e1 offering a trade of the other
pair of rooks which capablanca doesn't
mind rook captures King captures and now
comes King to e7 just you know
centralizing the King given further
kingi to Ilia him does the same and now
Bishop to d6 we have King to e3 trying
to improve the position of the King even
further if it captures King book capture
here we have Bishop to c5 check and now
King to eat you and here you can see
that we already mentioned with 2 both
are still having the bishop fair it's
hard for either player to make any
progress here a couple Blanca just
repeated Bishop to d6 we have King 33
Bishop to c5 King T to Bishop to d6 King
to e3 and after Bishop to c5 it was in
this position that the players agreed to
a draw you could go for Bishop captures
instead of for example instead of King
III Bishop captures screen captures but
then it's just a completely equal
position with bishops of the same color
and the chances are most likely you are
you are going to well there's a higher
chance you were going to lose this
position against kappa blanka didn't win
this position against cup of wonka so
it's not something i didn't was
interested in doing but yeah this is a
like I mentioned game for the two of
have ever played and the first time I
let him did not lose a game against
Capablanca so next time you are you know
talking about chess with your friends
and family do tell them that made a 15
in 1914 was a great day in the life of
Alexander him as it was the first time
he faced against the Cuban legend hosts
a row kappa blanka without losing a game
Sam I read somewhere that that Bobby
Fischer actually said that
capablanca wasn't all that great at
playing the endgame he just he was just
so great at it the middle game that he
always you know ended up in a winning
game game and it's you know there were
always better moves to be played in
couple uncas indians but his opponents
never pushed him you know to achieve
this end game excellence that he he
might have achieved if his opponents
were stronger players but yeah most most
of the times people just thought a
couple Marco was a brilliant end game
player were in fact he just played the
middle game to to such an extent
perfectly that the end game was winning
all along it's just that his opponents
maybe didn't know it but I am Here I
even played an excellent game and you
know a couple one guy had to settle for
a draw here but okay with the black
pieces so that's it for this game we
we've finished the first half of the
second part of the tournament for more
games remaining in the 1914 tournament
of San Peterburg Capablanca still
strongly in the lead without a single
loss so far in this tournament I will
see if he can manage it with this tempo
for four more games
he still has to face all four of his
opponents Alaska Irish Ally him and
Frank James Marshall his old rival and
we'll see how it goes
sure attends the game I do hope you
enjoyed it I would like to thank Paul
staples is Milesi I'm Stefan month at
Joseph Conrad and Kyle a cast for a
contribution to my channel thank you a
lot I really appreciate it as usual you
can check two of my previous videos here
think of for watching and I will see you
soon are continuing the Capablanca saga
but also checking up on your suggestions
and what's going on in the world I think
all and I will see you soon